>>> TO AVOID ARMAGEDDON NASA
ANNOUNCING THE SPACECRAFT PUSHED
AN ASTEROID OUT OF ORBIT AFTER A
DELIBERATE CRASH LAST MONTH.
THE GOAL WAS TO SEE IF SLAMMING
INTO THE ASTEROID COULD CHANGE
ITS COURSE JUST IN CASE A BIGGER
ASTEROID ONE DAY THREATENS
EARTH.
>> NOW THIS IS A WATERSHED
MOMENT FOR PLANETARY DEFENSE.
AND A WATERSHED MOMENT FOR
HUMANITY.
>> LET'S BRING IN CNN SPACE AND
DEFENSE CORRESPONDENT KRISTEN
FISHER.
IT TOOK A WHILE TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
IS IT WORTH IT?
IS THE PAYOFF THERE?
>> Reporter: YOU AND I HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR WEEKS.
WHAT WE LEARNED YESTERDAY WAS
THIS MISSION WAS MORE SUCCESSFUL
THAN NASA EXPECTED.
WE KNEW THE DART SPACECRAFT HAD
SUCCESSFULLY HIT THIS ASTEROID A
LITTLE OVER TWO WEEKS AGO.
WHAT WE DID NOT KNOW IS IF NASA
ACHIEVED THE PRIMARY OBJECTIVE
WHICH WAS TO MOVE ITS ORBIT JUST
A LITTLE BIT.
IT ORBITS THIS LARGER ASTEROID O
THE GOAL WAS TO PUSH IT CLOSER
TO THIS ASTEROID TO SEE IF THEY
COULD DO IT.
WHAT THEY FOUND WAS SHOCKING.
BECAUSE THEY WERE EXPECTING TO
CHANGE THE ORBIT BY ONLY ABOUT
10 MINUTES.
IN REALITY THEY WERE ABLE TO
CHANGE IT BY 32 MINUTES.
BEFORE IMPACT THE ORBIT WAS 11
HOURS AND 55 IMPACTS, AFTER
IMPACT, 11 HOURS AND 23 MINUTES
AROUND.
THAT'S A CHANGE OF ABOUT 4%.
THE WAY THEY WERE ABLE TO
DETERMINE ALL OF THIS IS USING
GROUND BASED TELESCOPES.
TELESCOPES YOU AND I ARE USED TO
ON THE GROUND, ON PLANET EARTH,
LIKE THIS ONE IN CHILE, THAT'S
WHY IT TOOK TIME FOR YOU AND I
TO LEARN WHAT WE'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR ALL THIS TIME.
>> THAT LOOKS LIKE THE MORE YOU
KNOW LOGO, THE PICTURE, I
THOUGHT THAT THE WHOLE TIME.
THE GOAL OF THE MISSION WAS TO
SEE IF IT WAS FEASIBLE TO MOVE A
POTENTIAL EARTH-THREATENING
ASTEROID IN THE FUTURE WITHOUT
TRAINING A RAG TAG GROUP OF OIL
DRILLERS INCLUDING BEN AFFLECK
AND BRUCE WILLIS, BECAUSE THEY
MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE.
>> YEAH, WE LEARNED HUMANITY MAY
NOT NEED BRUCE WILLIS AND BEN
AFFLECK.
THIS IS A IMAGE FROM YESTERDAY
TAKEN ON SATURDAY, ALMOST TWO
WEEKS AFTER IMPACT.
AND LOOK AT THIS TRAIL HERE.
THIS IS TWO WEEKS AFTER IMPACT.
YOU CAN SEE THIS TRAIL OF DEBRIS
COMING FROM THE ASTEROID THAT
STRETCHES ABOUT 6,000 MILES
LONG.
THAT'S KIND OF THE POINT OF
IMPACT, THAT'S THE TRAIL.
CHECK OUT THIS OTHER IMAGE THAT
NASA RELEASED YESTERDAY AT THE
BRIEFING.
THIS WAS TAKEN BY THE SMALL
SATELLITE THAT WAS TRAILING,
SPYING ON THE DART SPACECRAFT
AND THAT'S THE MOMENT OF IMPACT.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT WHAT NASA
WANTS TO STUDY ARE THE PLUMES OF
DUST THAT COME OUT FROM THE
MOMENT OF IMPACT.
WHAT'S NEXT?
THAT'S THE BIG QUESTION HERE.
WHAT NASA HAS DONE IS PROVEN
THIS TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY COULD
WORK IF THERE WERE EVER A BIG
EARTH KILLING ASTEROID
POTENTIALLY HEADED OUR WAY.
THIS WAS NOT.
THE KEY IS YOU HAVE TO DETECT IT
YEARS IN ADVANCE.
FAR IN ADVANCE SO YOU CAN SEND A
SPACECRAFT LIKE DART, HIT IT AND
PUSH IT 4% OFF ITS CURRENT ORBIT
SO THAT ULTIMATELY YOU CAN MOVE
ITS TRAJECTORY BY A LARGER
MARGIN AND HOPEFULLY SAVE THE
PLANET, ALL OF US.
THE KIND OF TECHNOLOGY THE
DINOSAURS WOULD HAVE LOVED.
>> THEY DIDN'T HAVE THAT LEAD
TIME IN THE MOVIE "ARMAGEDDON"
BUT THAT'S OBVIOUSLY WHAT YOU
NEED.
THIS IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
STORIES THAT YOU COVERED.
THANK YOU FOR WRAPPING IT ALL UP FOR US